[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Thank you, veterans.
Thank you for quiet mornings,
family breakfasts, morning
walks, and safe streets.
For builders, both of
cities and of homes.
Thank you for realists,
ordinary optimists, coffee shop
companies, and
boardroom companies.
For freedoms, choices, beliefs.
Thank you for your oath.
Thank you for 2:00 AM night
watches, 5:00 AM ruck launches,
for scrubbing,
mopping, plunging,
for papers, plans, and routes.
For six hour convoys and
six month deployments.
Thank you for following
orders, leading your team,
and carrying your
brothers back home.
Thank you, veterans, for
sticking to your oath
so that we all can wake up to
another quiet morning tomorrow.
[MUSIC PLAYING]